foreign
welcome baits what's up jacob jiminez
what's up
savannah savannahs hi juliana gomez
julian gomez
love you back what's up everybody how
are we doing
episode two oh
okay sound works
sound works hello everybody
we're about to do this
i think this is the episode where they
come together
and they're not 20 minutes early
releasing this episode like the last
time
so
just gonna put on my trusty rock jacket
project rug nova gaming you're at work
nice
respect are you going to be able to
watch the show
do i expect any cameos uh
[Music]
i don't know um
i feel like there are people who i think
would make sense to show up like rowdy
showing up in the first episode
made sense um i like that marvel
isn't they're not trying to
like force anything like
with the one division uh series finale
and everything like that
uh i think you know we all thought it
was going to be like
oh especially me like i'm the most
guilty of it um
maybe me and eric boss at new rockstars
uh
we we i think really grandsized that um
i don't know if that's a word grandized
that finale
to like be like this huge thing and
everything like that and you know just
it didn't happen
and and i think it's just because
like i realized that marvel's just
trying to
stick to the actual stories that they're
telling right like one division wasn't
about
doctor strange and mephisto it was about
wanda
and vision and so of course you need a
villain so
you know that's what it is but hello
whether it's the morning for you whether
it is the night for you i guess
technically it is the morning for me
because it's 12
49 a.m but uh i know people over
in europe right now and all the other
continents are
definitely definitely later on
maybe in the morning for you guys the
actual morning not like you know stupid
early in the morning
but i feel good i feel awake i feel
energized i feel confident about this
episode going in that we are going to
love it i'm really excited for that
let's just refresh because last week it
came out no
what did i just press no don't press
that okay
let's get a timer going on for everybody
who wants to
watch it in sync uh what do i oh
stopwatch
stop watch that's what i always do
cool so as usual i'll show a little bit
no sound because i i of course i i can't
show any sound
uh for those asking yes we're still
doing the discussion with supes
and brad and chris after this
uh it's always after we watch separately
um
let me text them right now actually and
let me make sure the falcon
wonder soldier hasn't begun yet because
last week it started like 20 minutes
early
let's switch over to this computer let's
do a little refresh here
oh the site's already having some
problems i think
oh episodes two's out who's ready for it
who's ready for it
we ready to start i'll give everybody
just a second
everybody just a second to uh before i
press play here
let me show you guys here
whoops that's tiny
oh this screen's all out of whack all
right that's not that's not the right
one hold on
uh nope
okay so that is gotcha found it
let's fix this here there we go and
it's out so
whenever everybody's ready we're going
to start this it looks like we're
looks like everybody is about ready uh
for those asking about the giveaway
tomorrow as soon as i wake up which i
don't know because i usually go to bed
at like 9am for this thing
after these things um i'll announce a
giveaway winner um i'll get with taya
and we'll choose
um it's random of course i know a lot of
people are saying please pick me sorry i
wish i could pick you all
um but it's completely random all my
giveaways that i've ever done
are completely random i use a program
called tubebuddy they have what's called
pick a winner program on
inside of it and that's what i use
they're completely random so there's no
bias or anything like that because i
have some friends that enter and stuff
like that too so all right guys i'm
gonna start this timer and
i think let's see here
i think we're gonna start
let's see if it works alright we are
starting
let's do it
uh i've started and now it's doing
previously this is a crazy place right
now
let me see if i can remind you all torn
apart
the world's broken symbols are nothing
without the women and men that give them
meaning
thank you captain america but this
belongs to you tell me about your most
recent nightmare
look i know that you have been through a
lot but you got your mind back
all right here we go pardoned you're
free to do why
oh bam right there you see these guys
these are the guys you got to worry
about
they call themselves the flag smashers
if they want a world that's
unified without borders so this
fortunately we can't have sound coming
in but
that's not what i want to do hold on
oh it just froze for me oh no here we go
we're starting
oh we're starting with a
little zipper here oh
oh it's usage
let the put this down here so it's not
that big so i don't get black for it
interesting
interesting
since i've been a captain before
obviously but this is different
so he's actual military man
oh
he says i don't want to fail them
everyone expects him to be something
so he's a good guy
i mean u.s agent right
i wonder oh that's his it's his wife
all right okay
captain america
so he's prepping to be the new captain
america
dang
so two weeks ago he was doing special
ops in chile
i just want to do the job
star spangled man with the plan epic
is everything good with the stream let
me make sure here
time to go to work oh here it is this is
where they're gonna this is where
they're gonna oh marvel logo
i hear the band i hear the band playing
i hear the band here we go
i just know the soups isn't streaming uh
time i'm at right now five minutes the
band just started playing
right here so here he comes good all
captain america
and there you have it there is the title
card
oh look at that look at that
that's pretty cool
captain again your new captain america
dang
uh soup's his pc broke i just texted him
you guys keep saying i'm gonna get
copyrighted am i playing sound or
something
oh you can kind of hear the music
dang that's crazy
he's throwing the shield
he says i'm not tony stark i'm not dr
banner
he has guts is what he says
i'm not sure how you guys are are
hearing it
he's watching like all all
pissed and then there's sam watching all
pissed as well
dang cap
is back oh
shouldn't have given up the shield
salmon falconer talking
all right good you're not supposed to
hear it because i'll get copy strike for
it
what do you want me to do call america
and tell him i changed my mind
great reunion you had no right to give
up the shield
oh he's going to talk about the flag
smashers yep
yep he's strong
part of the big three
black smashers
this is the part in the commercial that
we got i'm gonna see if he's part of the
big three
what big three
androids aliens and wizards
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
i'm right i just came up with that huh
this episode is 43 minutes long by the
way oh no
it's 49 minutes long oh here we go
staring contest
[Laughter]
let's move this keyboard out of my way
what's our plan
you can't call me buck
i have a plan
and there he goes jumping out
uh i don't know if mega red's gonna be
in this i really hope so
[ __ ] just said he doesn't need a
parachute because they're 200 feet or
below
oh this dude about to jump out the oh i
ripped it off
he yells us he jumps out
oh my gosh you're kidding me
look he just freaking drops out of the
sky
i have all of that on camera red wings
watching him
oof this is epic
oh they found a place
he hates red wing he's like swatting at
red wing as it flies around
you can hear everything i'm not
understanding how you guys are hearing
everything
i'm really not
hmm
i think they're smuggling weapons
i don't think i can hear it
he just called him the white wolf
awesome awesome awesome awesome awesome
oh you can't hear anything okay cool
trolls
hey there just thank you can use
i'm not i never spell names because it's
always a trap
but thank you for the super chat oh
that's a lot of people
there's a lot of people showing up oh
they are strong
holy crap they have to be some type of
super soldiers
oh they heard him
they heard him
there's an eighth person he thinks they
have a hostage and there they go
boys the falcon and the winter soldier
holy crap bucky's fast i've never
realized how fast bucky is
uh runtime's about 49 minutes
back scenes
this totally super soldier serums
he thinks he found the hostage but it's
it's not he's
she's going to kick his butt oh and
there he comes
and there it comes she's about to kick
him in the face got him
and there it is
oh they're totally super soldiers these
vast scenes that they have are super
soldier serums
smack to the base look at that they've
actually got
them
and here comes red wing
oh [ __ ] crabtree she broke right away
i've always wanted to do that um i don't
think soups and bread are gonna be in
after uh because soup's his computer
broke
oh sam's fighting out too oh snap that
throwing them back and forth between the
trucks
nice oh snap
new cap and i guess a new
bucky oh my gosh
awesome shield throwing look at that
oh that's cool oh that's cool
oh bucky's not happy bucky tried to take
the shield back and
this is a pretty baller scene though
holy crap
this is a pretty cool scene
oh bucky's in trouble oh no
oh holy crap they are strong they're
super soldiers
there's there's no way oh that's cool
uh i think it's hopkins is with him
is his name
um he's essentially gonna be the the
bucky to the new captain america
oh step he's shooting new captain
america shoots
oh [ __ ] to save bucky hardcore
those were all super soldiers i know i
freaking
knew it i freaking knew it please don't
kill him please don't kill him i
actually like him
don't kill him now nice
that's pretty dope
new cap let's go
i'm actually starting to i'm starting to
like this guy actually
oof well dang they beat him all
it's
eight super soldiers running loose is
what they just said like i freaking knew
it
oh they're meeting they're meeting
oh they don't want they don't want to
get in the car
there's no such thing as wizards
super soldiers i freaking knew it
oh bucky says just because you carry
that shield does not mean
you're captain america
trying to be friends
he said they hacked red wing and he said
you hacked my property
and he said it's government property so
yeah i like john walker and hoskins
actually i think they're just trying to
be good guys
ma hoskins
battle star epic
epic battle star um
that's awesome
he says not trying to be steve
oh he just wants to be the best cop he
can be
dang
dang dang dang well they introduced
battle star
that's hoskins ammar hoskins
and us agent john walker has a new cap i
don't hate him
i really don't i think he might just be
trying to be a good guy i do think he's
going to get a super soldier serum and
start to get controlled by it
but here the flag smashers they're uh
they're they're looking yeah
let's find out what they're doing let's
find out what they're doing
interesting
wait is that
no that's not
is that zemo
no no that's not zuma no no
hey pretty yacht sharma thank you for
that i appreciate that
you took what was mine i'm going to find
you and kill you holy crap
no that's not that's not uh that's not
zemo
wiping aliases off carly
morgenthau
carly mcgunto is flag smasher
carla meganto is the name of flagsmasher
let me look that up
current flex yep i knew it
carl and gantho is the original name of
the original flag smasher
interesting
well sam and bucky got their butts
kicked
you all right
he said let's take this shield sam
new episodes released we're watching it
right now
oh ooh about to find some stuff out
there is someone
you should meet oh no oh he's gonna meet
isaiah bradley
no way oh this is getting really good
baltimore maryland
this is pretty cool
you're the falcon just falcon
my dad told me it's black falcon
that's pretty good
thank you bread yeah i appreciate that
you're awesome
dude they're about to this is this
isaiah bradley
this is totally isaiah bradley
hmm
interesting
see the korean war
oh isaiah bradley freaking
hey dude that's so cool
captain america before captain america
oh one of the ones that hide your fear
the most
dang
dang so he he beat bucky
i wanted to see if he got the arm back
or if he wanted to kill me
hello dress allison happy birthday hope
it's a good one
oh good this is this is insane this is a
great episode
so he he's one of the original super
soldiers
duel
he just showed he had a lot of strength
he's he was original one of the original
super soldiers
dang
now
dang sam's pissed nobody told him about
him
oh steve didn't know about him
oh
you know what this is
they really are addressing race in this
holy crap
dang
said he didn't tell anybody about isaiah
because
oh come on they're putting bucky under
arrest because he missed the court
mandated a therapy
therapy come on that's so lame
give the guy a break
dang bucky can't get a break sam can't
get a break oh go talk go talk to him
again sam
all right where is this email where are
we now no it's not yet oh
they're taking bucky to jail
there's this therapist
other man meeting the therapist
oh the new cap the new cap got him out
he just said bucky is good not going to
be going to therapy anymore she said he
authorizes he's like
me
she's she said the condition of your
release therapy session now
both of you that's hilarious so we're
gonna get the scene that we
yeah the scene that we saw from the
commercial right here
who would like to start dr raynor
i don't know who dr rayna is
rayner i don't know who that is
i'll look it up later
miracle question
the soul gazing exercise
so they're not doing uh or maybe they
are
i'm gonna enjoy this here we go
soul gazing exercise
there's good like stupid clothes
now look at each other in the eyes
they're gonna do a freaking staring
contest
having a staring contest
why did you give up that shield
we're getting intense now
[ __ ] you so you gave him that shield and
he threw it away like it was nothing
what did bucky just say
put the subtitles on
feels wrong about you is wrong about me
meaning maybe maybe bucky was the one
that was supposed maybe he feels like he
maybe should have taken the shield
oh so i'm saying i'll squash it right
now
when we're done we'll go on separate
lung vacations and never see each other
again
we watching it right now
thanks doc for making it weird i feel
much better
hair or a bug or something
oh he said what was rule number two
again she says don't hurt anyone she
looked at him and said goodbye
the new cop just wants to be friends
that's all he wants
morgenthau
tonight
dang
dang
bucky does not like captain america the
new one
oh oh the new cap just said word of
advice stay the hell out of my way
because sam and bucky said we're not
going to work with you
slovakia they're in slovakia now
pradyat sharma thank you for being such
a good fan
awesome fan but please stop spamming the
chat i'll have to time you out
the power brokers man dang it there's
gonna be like another
mysterious buyer person
like the employer
thank you thank you pratya sharma for
stopping and i appreciate you being such
a
such an awesome subscriber you're the
best
so what are we doing now there's so now
the flag smashers say
the flag smashers are running from
somebody else now so i wonder who the
big boss is we're about to find out
oh snap what is about to happen here we
go
oh my gosh he just pushed that over by
himself
yeah they're definitely super soldiers
who's this dude about the fight
come on show me who you're about to
fight come on show me
the beast boss what up this dude
straight up running at him
just ran at him and just got murdered
holy crap
so who are these people
is that was that taurus
no these are new people
another organization we have to worry
about
who is this guy now oh come on
let the theories begin
we're talking about hydra now
zemo they're talking about zemo
oh
we're going to go see zmo we just said
it
[Laughter]
oh dang
wait how long into the episode are we in
oh we're almost freaking done we're not
gonna get to see him
crap
but he seems to be under very heavy
security oh yeah he's in like a stupid
high
cell
where i'm at this part right here there
he is
zebo what up and that's the end isn't it
that's the end all right let's see if i
can find any let's see what they show us
kind of here huh
based on the marvel comics
executive producer kevin feige let's
look at these pictures of the shonas
capital building yeah
that's a new symbol hmm
huh
yeah that was weird captain america took
like a really weird turn
read the new one like he
he was like all good and he like wanted
them on his side and the second they
were like no
we're not gonna work with you he's like
stay the hell out of my way
um well
uh
all right
well that was a pretty dang good
episode thank you mr anderson i
appreciate that
oh mr anderson from the matrix i get it
nice
so cap is back this poster right here
anthony mackie so yeah they did call the
rhyming rhino they call or
sam said it's the white wolf
which is epic oh look it put her in it
and it didn't it didn't say her name
emily ban heck
wait who's that oh just a missing prince
day break
um i i think walker's going to be a
super soldier
um
let me start with the zoom
no post credit scene what was that
uh let's see if there's like now we're
just in like final credits
[Music]
no post credit scene how how long of
credits are there hold on let's take a
look at this
there's almost seven minutes of critics
yeah i i saw that i saw that meme we're
not gonna do the mephisto rumors
uh we're not gonna do the mephisto
rumors for this
uh that's gonna be that's gonna be
different yeah maybe match before next
episode that's kind of what i'm thinking
because
maybe i don't know how
i don't know how zemo getting out of
jail is going to go down
um because i don't know like
you have to think they're not gonna be
able to like pardon him somehow like
they're just gonna go talk to him i mean
maybe they can i guess they can
um clearly they need his help because
hydra blah blah blah blah
like he was talking about at the end
this is really quite interesting
i like i like how captain america was
trying to be good and i think he is
trying to be good like the new captain
america
um but
there's something up with him right
because you can tell that
he got really pissed off when sam and
bucky refused to work with him
so
[Music]
i okay so people asking about zemo being
like good or bad so i interviewed the
director carrie scoglin
and when i asked her about zemo she said
whatever you expect him to do he's going
to do the opposite
so i think we expect him to be bad he's
going to be good
so yeah
yeah isaiah bradley is patriot um
that was cool and i definitely think
we're going to see a lot more of that
that was pretty good episode
um that scene
was pretty good i sense a theme here i
sense
about half action half like deep story
right like like race was a big part of
the story here right
which they said they're going to address
they're going to a dress race
so we have we have
the new captain america u.s agent john
walker right
who becomes captain america after steve
rogers in the comics and then we have
hoskins who is battle star who actually
takes on the mantle of bucky in the
comics before taking on battlestar
so that's straight from the comics too
jose bradley patriot
um what was the name of uh
uh how do i had a way her name was let
me look
carly carly morgantho
um black smasher in the comics is an
actual person it's not a group
now that person has a group but
he is an actual person and
that's her name i don't think she is
flag smasher
but that's just like a like an easter
egg right
um this easter egg i actually thought
that the shield stuff uh was pretty good
um hold on real fast i'm trying to start
this
zoom my theory on that whole thing about
what's going on so we saw isaiah how
does this work
uh how does that work this because i
don't think my camera will share it
yeah mine won't either so we just chat i
guess
i can't see your camera yeah this is
yeah okay
because my camera doesn't hook up
because i only have one pc right
yeah for those of you asking soup's
computer broke this week oh no
yeah so uh i guess he was uh
streaming and it just went down
which is very unfortunate so
this is a good episode uh the episode is
really good i wish we got more
but he's there he was there yeah hey
thank you clifton lover more i
appreciate that
so there's a lot
of uh like a lot of callbacks to
captain america comics in this one first
of all
they introduced uh battlestar hoskins
right who has taken the mantle bucky
before
um obviously usage and john walker was a
big part of this one which i actually
like
i liked him a lot in the beginning and
then he was like stare the hell in my
way i'm like oh okay
um it seemed like he was just a soldier
trying to like do the good thing like do
a good thing right
and i'm like okay i kind of like him and
he like really wanted to work with them
and that the shield throwing scene
like during that whole thing was pretty
awesome
it was crazy because at the very
beginning i almost wanted to like
captain america like i tried
right yeah yeah i was like i'm gonna
give this guy a go like the very
beginning opening
it was like hey this guy's trying
he wants to be a good guy but then he
kind of came off kind of like
arrogant almost during the second half
and it was like
stay out of my way it's like dude you
got your butt kicked by one chick
it's like
because i thought he was going to be
given a super soldier serum
and they were going to control him that
way so i'm wondering
i'm wondering if that's like something
like that's going on because we didn't
see what happened
in between they clearly went somewhere
after they dropped bucky in them off
and oh man i don't uh
so i have something of a theory just
from what we saw we saw the text
you stole something that belonged to me
i think that
thunderbolt ross or somebody working
with thunderbolt ross
that's a good thing thunderbolt ross got
the serum from isaiah who was introduced
to us as a black superhero
black super soldier from way back when
from bucky's era
so he was testing him in jail for 30
years okay
they figured out how to get the super
serum from him the flag smashers during
the blip or during some time
stole all of that and used it on
themselves for their own agenda
and this is somehow going to lead to the
thunderbolts and zemo's going to head
that off with thunderball ross
that's my that's where my head's at
right now
that's not a bad theory i like that um
where you at
um well i think at one point in time
there was a
hold on real fast i'm trying to check my
audio no yeah you're good okay
hold on because everyone's saying you're
super loud
so let's check this real fast yeah just
turn me down no okay
you know um so
that's a good theory i think thunderbolt
ross is definitely going to be involved
in this some way shape
form he's been behind since
the
he's been behind like super soldier
stuff for a very long time since like
the incredible hulk
he was doing the weapons plus program
there's
there's the whole scene with abomination
um
and they revealed like it said like
weapons plus program on it which is
basically is just the super soldier
program which actually turns into the
weapon x program which
is responsible for creating wolverine
and deadpool and a bunch of other
mutants
um there was a
and i can't remember the name
there was a
leak or something we saw like the biker
gang with like the mephisto logo pretty
much
yeah that was pretty crazy not saying
it's mephisto at all
but it was a thai italian in connection
to
the old gang that wolverine was
associated with so perhaps it's some
type of mob boss or gang or something
like that
um i actually think the power
broker could be ross and i bet you i bet
you it's going to be ross and i bet you
this actually eventually does lead to
zemo joining the thunderbolts
yeah yeah yeah yeah and they're all kind
of being started
um yeah and i like you know they
introduced isaiah bradley
bradley which is patriot which has a you
know they they said they
they were going to explore like race
like what does it mean for a black man
oh yeah i was very eminent he isaiah
bradley is like a very big part of that
in the comics
uh with race and everything like that so
now a lot of people are wondering about
omega red you know
being introduced uh maybe he could be
introduced as a super soldier instead of
a mutant
yeah i think he could be part
of of
uh thunderbolt ross's like whole program
here
i think i i think that he could be
some type of like abomination like you
know
like was in the incredible hulk movie i
think that's a very big possibility
um but i like it i like the depth that
they're adding to everything you know i
i think they're definitely doing a
really cool job integrating the comics
in this particular like they always have
throughout the mcu but in this
particular
show it feels very comic book driven
yeah and they had the cool easter eggs
with the comic the original captain
america comic book and
we're getting what that looks like from
leaks a very original
captain america falcon wardrobe so i'm
excited to see that as well here hold on
for those of you who don't know chris is
um in order my best friend my roommate
and host of cosmic culture
uh i'm pulling up i'm gonna pull up your
stream
it's me so people can kind of see that
guys i shaved i'm looking cute today
i'm shaved i kind of shut a little bit
chris you're making me watch an ad
um i got two lit so yeah me i think
there could be like a pretty good
omega red type of deal here yeah yeah um
they're hinting at it really heavy they
really are hinting at it pretty heavily
did
thunderbolt ross finally perfect the
serum a question coming from
moomin um i think somebody protected it
i perfected it and i think the text that
the flag smashers got
was from either thunderbolt ross
directly or somebody who works with him
so i'm gonna go ahead and say yes as a
theory well it all has to stem from
thunderbolt ross like in some way shape
or form right
like because he was the one who like
started it he's the one he's the center
of all that right right right so
he he is you know it has to somehow stem
from him so
i think i think we see thunderbolt ross
no matter what especially if you
consider the fact that
he's really the one who is responsible
for the sokovia accords and everybody
being on the run
like that's him and they mentioned that
today you know falcon was talking to
bucky about it like do you want to be on
the run again and like
because excuse me because bucky you like
let's take back the [ __ ] bucky's pissed
he's super pissed that was crazy to see
the fire when he like approached sam
originally yeah
he's like why did you do that yeah and
and i think that's going to go back to
race again and
he says to him during that therapy
sessions like i don't think you or steve
will ever understand but you just have
to assume i did the right thing and it's
like
you know there really isn't a response
to that because he has his reason and
we've spoken with the actor both you and
i anthony mackie who said you know i
wasn't ready to say goodbye to captain
america
he hasn't said that yet in the show but
there's definitely part of that
lingering
yeah yeah you know he mentioned that he
said you know
it was his captain america too and and
both martin spellman the writer
and producer and uh
cary scotland the director they both
said
that you know what does this mean what
does this mean
for a black man to carry that shield
or is the world ready for it is sam
ready for it
we don't know what could be going on
behind the scenes somebody could have
went up to him and said
because so what happened in the comics
for those of you who aren't that
familiar with uh
with sam in the comics before we come to
captain america when steve rogers was
done like being captain america um
nick fury suggested sam wilson falcon
to be the next captain america and they
said no
because they said the world was not
ready for a black captain america
um now obviously this was written in a
much
earlier time than we are right now but
um that could be something that is going
on right now
perhaps sam did want to be the next
captain america
but perhaps some people maybe came in
and said
you know may maybe you don't be captain
america i don't know if the world really
is ready for that you know right
i mean they went and got another white
dude with blonde hair pretty much tried
to look like steve to replace him so
yeah right i mean that was just
government's doing what they want
right yeah and you know i was really
rooting for freaking
john walker in the beginning of this
episode when he's like i just want to do
a good job
and even the uh the therapist
dr raynor i uh reina
uh i couldn't i i've never i can't
recall anything
on her um like right off top of my head
that's not a character that kind of like
comes to my mind that i've seen in the
comics before um i'll have to you know
re re-watch the episode obviously when
we do the breakdown and everything and
and look what they say with the
subtitles on but um she doesn't come in
my head but even she was like
oh we you know we did some missions
together me and john walker like so they
go
she goes back with captain america so no
matter what is happening
with john walker now the new captain
america no matter what's happening with
that
he used to be at some point in time and
maybe in his court
was a good guy so
we've because we've seen leaks
video leaks of him bashing people's
faces in
with the shield right like
uh well it was cool during that fighting
scene for a moment when captain america
shows up
and you see do we call him captain
america i mean it's not wrong i mean
that's what he is captain america by all
he's got the shield which is the symbol
of hope
he's got the title he's got the power
he's got the bad kid
he does have sidekick battles i was
excited to see him
but while they're fighting there before
they got their butts completely handed
to him which was extremely disappointing
it was cool to see that and i actually
thought to myself you know it would be
cool for falcon to just be falcon
bucky just to be bucky the white wolf
which is a cool name drop they did yeah
that was cool
um and have a captain america but then
this guy's all like i
am the government and stay out right
you're gross like you don't stand for
anything steve stood for
yeah pretty much like oh it's government
property and i'm the government you know
so it's like i'm the government so i
hacked your red wing
and then he's like oh yeah they're gonna
be working with me so he's not gonna be
attending therapy he's like we're not
done yet who authorized that he's like
i did so uh real fast
japheth contreras the power broker aka
curtis jackson
is the one who gave us agent super
soldier powers in the comics okay he
gives powers to anyone willing to pay
thank you for that super chat i actually
think
they might change this and make it
thunderbolt ross
yeah i agree with that i think
thunderball ross is gonna be the center
of this
i think they might i really do think
that
it's gonna be something like that oh
brad just texted me
i'm sweet i don't know he's he's got an
early morning um
so cool cool for that thank you for
pointing that out
i think that might change that the
thunderbolt ross uh tope
made or taupe made i'm sorry i don't
know which pronunciation is right
thank you for addressing the race aspect
of the show man looking past this
superhero action stuff no no problem and
you know
it the director said they're going to
address that
and it's very real things that happen in
our world right now um
and you saw it right when the cops came
up
they weren't like asking falcon if he
was okay
they were asking bucky if he was okay
right like they were asking the white
dude he was okay
and they were in it looked like a
primarily black neighborhood
so it's like really weird that they like
it's just really weird that they would
just like be like that but i i think
especially with getting into patriotism
bradley i think we're gonna get a lot
into that
and i do think that
in one way shape or form that is
something that sam
had to deal with before deciding whether
or not he was going to take on the
mantle i think
somebody i think somebody said something
um jeff aquino aquino thank you so much
for that super chat bucky mentioned
that steve had a plan for sam using the
shield the steve rogers coming back
then john walker finally becomes u.s
agent um
i i don't know i i don't think steve's
gonna come back i think kevin feige
talked about that not too long ago and
and a lot of people were wondering said
like oh we shut it down but you know you
never really knows
um but i i i don't think
so okay let's bring this back to
and if i didn't say thank you for the
super chat thank you very much but let's
bring this back to one division
when we were like chris you know
mephisto's this and then and then doctor
strange is gonna come in
and you know all these other people are
gonna are gonna come pop in
and and you know when really it was
about
wanda vision it was about wanda and
vision so i think this show
is going to be about bucky and sam i
don't think it's gonna be about
steve rogers captain america do i think
old man cap is going to make an
appearance maybe in the last episode yes
yes i don't think he's dead i might not
even be chris evans but it'll be old man
cap
right yeah right it'll be something that
called
uh i don't think he's dead yeah uh
a big part of this is the fact i can see
a lot of people talking about here
um a lot of people thought u.s agent
was going to have some type of super
soldier serum i think he
i think he gets that at some point in
time what do you think you don't think
he has it yet
no because he got his butt kicked like
so how is he doing that crap with the
shield though he trained
right we saw well how does sam do it in
the previews that we've seen right
right um there's clearly like you know
peter parker spider makes a joke in
in civil war you know that thing does
not obey the laws of physics at all
right there's clearly something that we
don't understand here
that's true it's a big made up universe
what the heck is that
are we in the middle of earthquake right
now uh i didn't feel anything
okay it happens every now and then
right here we get earthquakes yeah
they're usually small um
so here's a theory that i have
what's that in the comics
before john walker becomes captain
america he
wants to be the next captain america and
he puts on he hires people
to put on like shows so he hires people
to go
and like mug people so he can go stop
them and seem like you know this very
patriotic person
and you know steve actually sees through
that and he's like you know please stop
that like don't do this
but um so but he does he hires these
people so at first i was kind of like
is the flax masters like a trick
are they or does john walker working
with them somehow
he's hired them to make them to make him
look good that's possible and the real
villains aren't actually the black
smashers they're like the people behind
the flag smashers trying to get them
like there's a lot there's a lot that
could happen there
i don't know if that's the route they're
going to go because he did want their
help
um so it wouldn't make sense to like
involve them to
if it was like it feels like fake
so noah says is the new captain america
going to be like a bad guy
so i don't think he's going to be a bad
guy
i think he's going to be a prop used by
the government or by somebody
for their personal agenda i mean there
was a leak going on talking about how
he's going to be brainwashed when he got
the
superhero serum and stuff like that i
think he wants to do a good job i think
he's a little bit cocky and he doesn't
really stand for the same stuff steve
stood for
exactly but i don't think he's a bad guy
i just think he's gonna be a prop but
that's that's actually who he
is like in the comics he he
he doesn't have the same morals and
ethics as steve he
so we saw he uses a gun he was taking
shots now
steve did too but primarily in the
i think like with the exception after
i can't recall if in winter soldier he
used a lot of guns
but yeah i was really thrown off by the
gun well so steve definitely used guns
and captain mary the first avenger
right right um clearly it was a soldier
and everything
but at like from civil war on i don't we
never saw him use a gun
all right so it's just been a long time
it threw me off
since he's used a gun um
but i do think he he doesn't care as
much
he's he he was a soldier and he was a
soldier for a really really really long
time
um so he could just be
yeah like warming up to be in captain
america i mean he was super nervous
about all of it even just going out and
getting interviewed by good morning
america he was nervous so i'm sure going
in and actually doing the fighting is
nerve-wracking for him as well yeah well
there's a lot that could be happening
here oh there's a ton that could be
it's all over they did do a good job
like with a bunch of callbacks and stuff
like that it's really cool how they're
wrapping that all in here um
you know introduction to usage was
pretty cool john walker
uh battle star isaiah bradley patriot
um and uh carly
uh i don't remember the name i don't
remember the last name
carly morganto what is the name
of flag smasher in the comics now black
smash was an actual person and this is a
group i don't think she is going to be
the the flag smasher right there's not
like a person that is flag smasher
but but i do think that's a cool little
callback uh cam k thanks for super chat
that shield must be a lighter version
from another timeline hence why steve
felt it was okay to give the sam
maybe we do know it's different and we
have not seen that story yet
i don't know if we're going to get that
story but it definitely was not getting
lucky yeah right we'll get in loki
somehow but it definitely wasn't the
same shield
that uh steve had like that he was using
throughout time
it was definitely different when he came
back and gave it to sam uh
uvd productions oh thanks for super chat
yeah i'm gonna have to get some
definitely gonna have to get some
what are we getting mods in my chat matt
stinks was super chat
i'm a mod the us agent isn't my cap but
the reason he's so good with the shield
probably because he must have been
a quarterback for his high school
football team well i think it could be
part of it i think he did mention that
in the beginning though right yeah they
said he was a player anyway
he said he was a player or something
like that yeah that's not a bad theory
that's not a bad thing you think so
i thought we were gonna get sharon i'm
surprised we didn't yeah i think they
name dropped her but she wasn't in it
when did they name dropper i didn't
catch that uh way back when bucky was
yelling at sam and bucky
samuel responded something like uh
trying to remember real quick
he was like last time oh no no no so
after they got a fight with captain
america he was like we need to go steal
the shield he was like last time we did
something like that
steve and i were on the run sharon was
wanted
so they did name dropper yeah
dang okay yeah i remember that i
remember that okay um
guys i'm going to time out everybody
who's saying but not so if you don't
stop her
now i mean please stop it's annoying
where is nick fury the one who brought
them all together in first place
so we saw at the end of spider-man far
from home that he is
up in space with sword
yeah and uh this happens right about the
same time as far from home so he's up in
space right now dealing with
inter-dimensional threats or crazy stuff
like that we haven't gotten that whole
story yet no
uh evan campbell thanks for that super
chat uh casey mcnatt
thanks for the super chat do you think
the power broker is somebody big or just
some kind of suit
no i i think it's this is just my theory
twisting it
uh thunderbolt ross uh yeah i think
that's uh
i think i was thinking that too chris uh
i was hoping it's not i was hoping
that's not a word but
i was i was hoping i was hoping it's not
something like uh um
what's it called the the buyer
or the what was the name for the ant-man
on the wasp that they used to
call the the person right uh the
employer or whatever it was
yeah yeah the client no wasn't the
client or something like that um
but you know he had like this mysterious
employer behind him or this mysterious
buyer and we never saw him
i hope that comes light one day i hope
that's not like this yeah i don't know
if thunderbolt ross
will have a direct connection but
whoever it is is going to be working for
him somewhere eventually
and we know he's showing up in the black
widow movie we've seen the little pym
particles or the superhero soldier the
super soldier serum or whatever it is
all that's going to connect somehow i
think personally i think so too
um i really think so too uh jonathan
eder
thanks for the super chat okay john
walker throwing the shield better than
cap in any previous movie is bad for him
john walker on the truck store on that
shield is bs it was very
interesting how much
he was insanely similar to cap
wasn't it like like they really
they really are trying to duplicate him
and they kind of like addressed that
when he was like
look i'm not trying to be steve um
you know i just want to be the best cap
the benefactor thank you thank you for
everybody holy crap
that's i can't believe i forgot the bit
of factor um
the benefactor there it is yeah yeah
yeah benefactor i hope it's not like
that like i hope it's not like oh we
never find out who it is
you know there's a mysterious power
broker benefactor guy uh
i think it's thunderbolt ross
but yeah they they did they did
make john walker very similar to cap the
way he threw it
uh oh it looked just like it looked just
like the training sequence they showed
who
visually i actually really enjoyed it
right i think we're all kind of like
hating this guy right now
i tried i tried really hard i was like
because we start off in that locker room
it's like open mind like hey
you know what let me give him a chance
and uh yep
nope nope didn't happen yeah towards the
end it's like stay out of my way that
quote was like yep i'm done yeah i will
try to pronounce this right
garrett gutierrez
thanks for super chat rest in peace red
wing i know he's gotta get a new one
though right i mean
yeah what the heck dude it's funny
because bucky's like i've been wanting
to do that i've been wanting to do that
this whole time
for years so here's an interesting
question that i actually had thought but
you're talking
um wow i'm rude how dare you no i was
just waiting
and then i forgot so we were under the
impression that that was stark tech
right
yeah i was thinking maybe and then john
walker's all like this belongs to the
government
yeah so did they seize a lot of stark
tech did they seize the company
like that's not something anybody has
touched on since we've returned from the
blip at
all but then you have far from home
where
peter parker has access to all of that
so
i'm really curious about what what's
going on with stark tech right now
because it still exists just because
tony's gone doesn't mean
it's gone
i don't know that's a good question
that's that's a really good question
because
i mean it looks like stark tech it
sounds like stark tech they said it was
dark tech or that at least
he said like what he said
yeah so it might i mean it really does
seem like star trek and that would just
start star trek stark tech
um and it would make sense obviously
that it would be stark
right you would assume yeah um
and it's weird because you know when
when in the first episode where sam was
addressing
uh you know like how do you all get paid
like there's have to be some fun did
stark pay for you guys like
stark's names was dropped a few times in
that first episode
and it makes you wonder because pepper
potts is in charge of it now
right um you obviously it's keep it's
still going right and start tech's still
there um
stark industries so i don't know
um i think his suit probably is some
type of tech because he was with
me such a long time who else could have
made that you know but
well you have to so you have to consider
this is new this is new
because post blue he hadn't
gotten new um
a new suit or anything after civil war
because he went on yeah but this is what
he has now is a new one correct
right yeah um but he went on the run
uh hold on another thing so that super
chat again plot twist john walker is
taskmaster
which is why he is a carbon copy of cat
that would be pretty cool actually
uh but wait
blackwidow was supposed to come up first
and perhaps
yeah perhaps if he i don't know if he
dies or something like that i literally
don't know that's not like spoilers just
kind of i mean
thinking out loud if he so if black
would have came out first he would have
died
that would disprove the taskmaster
theory but i like that i like that that
makes the sense
um corn thanks for the super chat kind
of off topic white russell
played quarterback and 22 jump street
kind of fun and around like yeah i
actually freaking love that movie
it's so good chris are you still there
yeah i'm here your stream's frozen
oh no unfreeze straight we're losing
internet if we're losing internet i
apologize everybody
if we uh say goodbye our internet
sometimes craps out on us
our internet does sometimes discord's
usually the first to go so we'll know
before you
uh nope everything's working on my phone
yeah everything's working for me here so
i don't know what's happening with
youtube here
hi here we go you're gonna make me watch
another ad
trying to think what other things i took
away or noticed from that because there
was
a lot of cool connecting parts in there
so the power so now okay so net yeah so
because
if we if we say um
that thunderbolt ross is the power
broker that makes sense because clearly
they are super soldiers
and he says you took something from me
i'm gonna kill you for it
that sounds like a ross thing to say
right i mean
yeah i think i i mean i'm not convinced
100 right we were convinced mephisto's
showing up and all this stuff but i'm
very certain
somewhere maybe not in this series but
we're gonna see
um that's the thunderbolts pulling the
strings
somebody asked where zemo was jailed i
thought it was germany but i wasn't 100
sure do you know where he was
uh was it not in
uh slovakia
sokovia i don't i have no clue where it
was
i don't remember yeah i really uh i
really don't remember
yeah so i don't recall but somewhere in
europe i think yeah uh for those asking
about soups and bread
soups computer crashed and it did not
come back
it did not make it did not happen he is
uh
he is yeah um yeah
so um for those talking about you know
that scene with the cops and everything
like that
i mean doubt's very intentional right
there it's not a racist show
they are addressing racism um
i don't really have much room to talk
about that there but that's what they're
doing
and that's you know it's coming from the
director and from the writer they they
said that so
i mean it is what it is uh i think it's
gonna dive deeper into that
um i think it's gonna you know kerry
skoglen director said that
if avengers in game was this outer space
other
worldly thing blah blah blah blah
falcon war soldier's very real world and
grounded and we can see that because
it's dressing like
the blip it's addressing like how do
superheroes get their money
you know and it's just kind of like it's
answering a lot of cool behind the
scenes questions yeah it really is
answering some behind-the-scenes
questions so
uh evan campbell thank you for that
other another super chat cap will get
the serum and then be bad or at least
not good because
he is not a good man and become use
agent yes i
agree i think i i think
i think they're gonna maybe make you
maybe in the next episode
try to get to like him again like they
were trying to get us to like him here
because i almost did
i almost liked him i tried i tried very
hard in the beginning to like him
but then it's like you know say the hell
out of my way it's like okay what you're
a little baby
you try to get these two to join your
cause and they're like no oh
screw you but um
but evan i do think i do think he's
gonna get some form of the the super
solid serum and i think um
sam four five nine one one one
one thank you for that the scene with
isaiah really was such an amazing intro
that character
so intense what will happen next think
they will visit soon yes i do
um i do because i think that's going to
be a pretty
big thing what happened i think sam's
going to be curious uh because even
uh bucky said you know no i didn't tell
steve
i i didn't want you know more to trouble
him with more things
right so so i think they left like for
people who don't know who that is for
people who don't know he's patriot and
like the history
of went down with him you know in the
comics i think
i think if you don't know that that's
like a big like
well who the heck is this guy right and
you have to address that in the show
so yeah i i i do i i think they're gonna
i think they're gonna come back i think
he'll definitely come back at some point
in
like a last minute fight and get
involved with i don't know who
yeah uh matt hutch thank you for
the super chat heartbreaking to see
bucky almost break down
when he says if steve was wrong about
you he's wrong about me yeah that was an
intense scene yeah
i mean this is
it's hard for both of them to to
[Music]
to be without steve they have to they
have to decide who they are
as individuals now you know who
that's that was a big part of the first
episode for bucky
going through therapy what do you want
you know it's like who who am i now
that uh you know steve's gone uh that
that the world isn't seemingly being
targeted by you know
a big purple alien uh
i think it's gonna be a big part i think
there's gonna be a lot of emotion
pirate man thanks for super chat the
blackwood movie takes place after the
events civil war
oh yeah long before i've been wait yeah
so john walker couldn't be yeah you're
right you're right i think that's going
to give us a lot of preface and free
story to
you know the whole thunderbolt thing
we're talking about and what thunderbolt
ross has been up to this whole time
right i think if the black widow movie
came out before i i'm going
to assume we would have a much more
theories about like the thunderbolts and
stuff like that
uh yeah so food blogger's kitchen
jordan what's up my man thanks for super
chat how's it going newcap is crooked
yeah let's just you know do cab is
definitely crooked i mean
there's something going on you know and
that that's how he is in the comics he's
not
a great a guy he's he definitely doesn't
have
morals or the same ethics as steve
rogers i don't think anybody really will
um because i think even sam can be more
intense and even bucky can be more
intense you know
i think that's what made steve really
really great um
so uh mr anderson
mr anderson thank you for that super
chat ten dollars
i'm curious about your ideas on the flax
masters and what they wanted
with the best scene and who made them so
strong is ross using power broker as an
alias
thanks for awesome watch party good
night hey thank you for joining i really
appreciate that i do think ross is using
the power broker as an alias now
um as somebody pointed out uh the power
broker is somebody from the comics
um an actual person but i think they'll
if it was me i think that i would change
that um i would make it ross because i
do think ross is
in the background somewhere and the
whole i'm gonna kill you
thing like i don't know just sounds like
ross to me because ross is crooked too
and who who has the power
to elect a new
right who's in charge i should say just
actually make the decision
to make john walker captain america like
a crooked
you know captain america he he does
um he's got a lot of power you know
enough to put
the avengers in jail half of them in
jail uh to do this kobe court you know
like he has a lot of power so i think
i really think yeah i i re
i really really think that he's behind
everything i think that's what we're
dealing with
that's what my thoughts are on the same
thing yeah watching it she got a text
from somebody right
you stole what belonged to me which i
can only oh right yeah yeah
or whatever you're using right right
yeah yeah so
so who's who do we know that has been
obsessing over the superhero
for the last yeah him 15 years of the
mcu right
him i mean literally since the hulk
really i mean geez so i mean
that one's on the nose i think which
might be why it's not true but it seems
very
right it's it
it might be too obvious right
nowadays who even knows anymore with
marvel but that seems to be lining up
pretty evenly we're gonna see him again
on black widow
and zemo's involved maybe deadpool
dead bulbs behind behind everything um
so uh i am trying to block all the
trolls guys sorry about that
um so
overall
i think it's a good good episode
yeah i'm trying to give us good action
it gave us good
answers it just i mean it left us with
the zemo question but
that's not really a surprise or anything
like that it's not your finger it's just
i wanted that right uh so for those
asking no i don't think
i don't think zemo is behind the power
brokers he's locked up but
i mean if if he wasn't snapped he's been
in jail for at least seven years
oh yeah that's a good question if he was
snapped
you know
mr anderson you just became a moderator
thank you
there you go thanks for the donuts um
i made you watch the totally off topic
but i made you watch the matrix movies
for the first time like a year ago
yep we watched it preparation for the
fourth one
um i've never seen them before guys gasp
i i think this eight and a half nine
out of ten uh i preferred this one of
the first one i probably would have
given the first one
uh six and a half or seven to be honest
yeah
and that's because it's introductory
whatever you know prologue of course
it's always like
i'd probably give this one a solid seven
or an eight
i'd give it eight and a half yeah
between the two of us warren is a lot
more um
friendly critic than i am i'm always
walking out of movies like well this was
wrong and this is wrong awards or yeah
that was the best
it's really hard for me so a lot of
people are always like oh you hyped
things up and blah blah blah i genuinely
enjoy it
like we come out of all these movies and
words like this was awesome and this is
awesome
i'm walking out with my arms crossed
like well this was kind of garbage
it's true it's like uh uh
was the last star wars yeah that was
we walked down we're like well this is
the rising skywalker
i was geeking out oh like it was super
popular a lot of the time
and chris was like yeah it's not right
and i was like it was awesome
uh it's like i genuinely geek out about
these movies about this it is exciting
i get really excited so i do tend to
maybe maybe i do over-hyped things
noah as somebody who just saw all the
matrix for the first time last year
i highly recommend them yeah i was
forced to watch them and i am not upset
about it
yeah i i think both episodes were were
really
really good um they do a good job mixing
action story
uh comic book and old marvel
new marvel it's just a really good
all-around balance which for me is
really important
yeah it is they're doing a really good
job at
i don't like to say this but moving past
the original superheroes
no it's true of the mcu um they're doing
a really good job
um hold on christian flores thank you
for that super chat
do you think zemo will say bucky mission
report december 16 1991
yes i don't
that's a and that's a good question do i
think bucky has visited zuma so
uh no i want to say no because he was
dusted i mean
i mean he hasn't even talked to anybody
right he was
he was on the run he was dusted he came
back fought
it's six months later could he have
visited him in the six month period of
time
he could have but i don't think he could
have i don't think yeah um
yeah darius woods even if zemo was
blipped wouldn't he pop back up in the
same cell yeah
but he would have had five years to sit
there and scheme
i don't think he's getting out of that i
don't think he
i don't think he's i don't think he's
involved
yeah i don't think he's behind the
flagsmasters i think
he's going to get involved because he
hates
super soldiers for because that's the
whole deal
right his revenge and all that stuff
like that i think
i think that is what i think that is
what
is going to bring him into this he and
then i think he's gonna have a huge
character change like his whole i think
his whole story arc is gonna go in a
different direction especially if we
think he's gonna end up joining the
thunderbolts
like joining a superhero group is that
how he gets out of jail
cause like do they break him out of jail
or does thunderbolt ross or somebody
say yeah captain america seems to do
whatever the heck he wants
right yeah so bucky's in jail captain
america is like i got him out and he's
done with therapy
and whatever they'll you know steve
rogers did not have that kind of control
or influence with the government which
is a huge giveaway
somebody's pulling the streams and
they're using captain america
as the mask which is because he's not a
four-star
general or anything like that right
exactly he can't just walk into jail be
like nope this guy's good to go
so somebody somewhere is telling him
what to do and he's getting all this
clearance
which is what they wanted to do with
captain america originally with the
sokovia courts but he didn't want to
play ball
yeah so it's like somebody saying hey
captain america go do this you're good
to just say whatever you want
because you have this clearance from
this person who's up here
high up in the government yeah that's a
huge red flag
big shout out to mr anderson doing an
awesome job with like the first two
minutes of being a moderator
getting rid of all the freaking trolls
got some dummies over there
oh i got a lot of them and uh dummies
your dummies but mr anderson is mephisto
is now the new official uh uh slogan of
our chat
there you go um i am king nelson
what if zemo was being let out of a cell
and the prison guard got blipped and he
escaped along with the other inmates
so yeah i was thinking that like it
would have to be a very specific like
he was like walking out of a cell
to be like transferred somewhere he
didn't get blipped the guard got blipped
the keys dropped on the ground great you
know what i mean like it had to be a
very specific chain of events which
could have definitely happened
um i'm excited to see story i i i think
he's gonna hate super soldiers and
try to go against the flag's masters
because they're super soldiers i think
that's what it's going to be
um edsel god when santiago
go uh cap in the comics is primary
strategist leader and voice of reason
what it what's the future mcu like
without him especially major crossover
films well they're going to have to have
a character step up to be that um
they even mentioned that yeah
when uh what were they doing they were
trying to when bucky followed him along
and he's like cap had a plan and you
don't
right yeah i definitely brought that up
i think
this is going to be the build up
of sam becoming
captain it's going to be a buildup of
him
like growing and being the guy has a
plan being the guy that has a strategy
um yeah we'll have to see all those
weaknesses first
well because let's think about the
heroes that exist right now
who's going to lead now we have a lot of
new characters coming but who's going to
lead
uh you're strange isn't much of a team
doctor strange not really a leader
you know um spiderman's got his hands
full spiderman could maybe lead the
young avengers he's not going to lead
the real avengers i don't think he's cuz
he's so young captain marvel is like a
really cosmic
uh character who i think isn't going to
spend you know so much time
on earth um thor again he's got stuff to
do although you know new asgard is on
earth but who knows what's going to
happen in the portland thunder
uh who knows what's going to happen with
hulk but again banner's not much of a
leader
um he's kind of a quiet guy you know as
banner not the hulk
um
it's gonna be there's a big huge void
right now that needs to be picked up
yeah and they mention that too captain
america
uh the new or john hashtag not my cap he
mentions it
and he's like i'm not bruce banner i'm
not tony stark he didn't say i'm not
steve rogers though which i thought was
pretty interesting
uh well he did he he did say that he
wasn't trying to be
replaced steve he's right he said that
into right he said i'm trying to be the
best captain america
but he when he was on good morning
america he's like i'm not bruce banner
i'm not tony stark
it's like that's interesting that you
named those two out of everybody
you could have named like bruce banner's
still alive and i mean yeah tony's dead
but it was just a weird name drop like
i'm not bruce banner yeah oh you know
what guys you're right i was mistaking
isaiah bradley for elijah bradley elijah
bradley's patriot
um and he could be coming for the uh
young avengers that's my bad um
yeah well i like this episode a lot
better we're getting better i thought it
was really really really good
uh it was good to see that
i actually thought they were going to
come together in quite a different way
but it's good to see them just like
which just showed up he just showed up
that was like okay
i was like okay good we don't need to go
through like hey sam sorry i haven't
been returning your text messages you
know we should meet
up and stuff like that you know like uh
something like that
so yeah yeah um yeah
uh i was glad that they kind of just
jumped into that
they didn't really waste time with that
they did have the therapist scene
which was uh which was good but yeah
again going
like going back to kind of what you said
about like the power that this new
captain america has you know steve
rogers didn't have that
so i wonder i really i think that's an
interesting
red flag i'm really thinking thunderbolt
ross is behind us
yeah i feel the same way yeah
so well guys this has been awesome uh
mister and there's some work to do
yeah mr anderson you can email me um
at warren my name w-a-r-r-e-n at
thecosmicwonder.com
um and let's talk there thank you so
much for uh being an awesome mod
right away up to get um guys this was
awesome
uh yeah next week we'll have the other
two guys with us soups and uh
brad the computer's crashed so
it was just us today hope we were
entertaining uh it seems like most of
people enjoyed this episode
with the exception of you know a small
group of people which you know
you do you you like the things you like
no big deal there
i thought i'm gonna give it a eight and
a half out of
ten i liked it better than the first
episode i did yeah i think it's
definitely getting better and i think
the next episode is gonna be
pretty insane yeah i can't wait till we
get zemo
and sharon carter and it all starts to
go down back together
and we better freaking figure out
who the power broker is i it at some
point
we we need to figure out who it is it
needs to be revealed thunderbolt ross
uh i think it's the benefactor they're
the same person that would be actually
pretty crazy if he was the benefactor
but that's the theory from the day yeah
right yeah that's a youtube video to
make
youtube videos you're gonna have to uh
gonna have to do that yeah so i mean
this episode dressed a lot of dress race
which some people don't like but that's
a real thing
that was interesting it was of some
pretty heavy race stuff it was heavy it
was heavy it was cool to hear it and
there'll be more of that coming in too
there's definitely going to be more than
that um it's pretty heavy there's you
know still
i i don't think he's done with a
therapist i i really don't think he's
done that therapist
i love that they made a joke out of it
with the couple's therapy
yeah the the couple's therapy was pretty
good the two were pretty good
uh soul gazing that's what she called it
you know yeah
they played did a game of uh
you know contest that was pretty good so
i think next week we get emily bank camp
and uh as sharon carter and zemo as well
daniel
in action yeah um hmm
yeah everything's gonna be good guys so
all right guys that was pretty awesome
we're gonna get to work
working on the breakdown we're gonna
watch this like four more times now
uh what have we been busting these out
chris in like
four hours five hours uh this is a
pretty long episode and we're starting
at zero so probably about
6 37 yeah so
[Music]
i'm gonna say four or five hours six at
the most we're gonna get this breakdown
out
throw it up on youtube be on the lookout
for that notification
or sometimes both channels sometimes the
notification takes a
crap and uh it doesn't go out but yeah
if you're not subscribed to chris at
cosmic culture
that's me do so now and
let's hope the omega red stuff uh you
know ends up happening maybe he's some
weird creation of the weapons plus
program so
uh no more super chats please because
the stream is a little bit delayed
um so if you're listening now no more
super chats please i don't want to miss
any
before we uh before we go um
and yeah we're gonna we're gonna see you
guys that
we'll see you next week for the live but
our breakdown's gonna be out
and four or five six hours so hey
everybody
this episode um i think it was better
the first and i think the next one's
gonna be even better as well so thank
you so much for
everybody who joined tonight um
i wanted to last thoughts on john walker
i wanted to like him but i think we're
going to hate him even more simply hate
him now
i love to hate him we're going to love
to hate this guy that's a great way to
put it so
all right guys everybody stay safe have
a great night watch it again